en el último vídeo terminamos con estos
dos resultados y comenzamos a pensar en
lo que significa tomar la derivada
parcial de una función vectorial y
obtuve estas clases de digamos
resultados bizarros ya sabes cuál fue el
punto de esto el punto en general es que
yo pueda darte las herramientas que tú
necesitas para entender qué es una
integral de superficie vamos sólo a
pensar vamos a dibujar el plano st el
plano de los parámetros y ver cómo se
transforma en la superficie r vamos a
hacer esto
entonces vamos a digamos que este es el
eje ok este es el eje y decimos que este
es el eje lgs y luego vamos a ver que
nuestra función vectorial nuestra
función de posiciones que tiene valores
vectoriales está definida entre ahí bnc
digamos por dar límites límites
arbitrarios y está t en 13 y de muy bien
entonces el área acotada por estos
límites esta área desde este rectángulo
justo aquí será mapeado será mapeado a
la superficie y si tú gráficas todos
estos puntos
eventualmente obtendrás la superficie
déjenme dibujar la superficie en tres
dimensiones una superficie
tridimensional así que este es nuestro
eje x nuestro eje i
y luego este es el eje zeta
perfecto y solo como pequeño
recordatorio podríamos ver algo como
esto si nosotros fuéramos digamos a
pintar este punto de aquí que pongo con
morado es decir cuando tc y ese es a ok
y ese punto está indicado por la función
rds de verdad así que este punto de aquí
cuando ese es a ips lo matamos digamos a
este punto justo aquí no sé cualquiera
no entonces como se obtiene de sustituir
a hice en esta función y obtenemos el
vector que señala a este punto verdad
justo allí
muy bien ahora digamos que esta línea de
aquí digamos si hiciéramos a ese a ese
constante constante igualada y variamos
t entre 6 de esta línea ok entonces esta
línea se manda a la superficie en alguna
otra curva digamos la estoy dibujando
algunos contornos arbitrarios allí tal
vez si cogemos otra constante digamos de
igual a c y variamos s entre a y b
tendremos esta otra curva que se vea
algo así no lo sé sólo estoy intentando
enseñarles un ejemplo entonces este
punto de aquí que corresponde a ese
igual a b y t igual a c ok corresponde a
ese punto que pinte con naranja ok y
evaluando r en esos puntos obtengo un
vector que apunta hacia y ahora este
modo digamos será otro vector que apunta
a este otro punto
y sólo para obtener una idea de qué se
parece voy a terminar haciéndolo un poco
más general digamos vamos a tomarnos un
punto o una línea medio azulada esto es
cuando te vale de iu variamos s entre a
y b entonces tenemos que empezar en el
punto morado y ahora variamos s tal vez
obtenemos algo como esto no lo sé así
que este punto de aquí correspondería a
este vector el vector que señala justo a
este punto y finalmente
finalmente esta línea que tomamos s
igual a b y variamos entre 6 d tendremos
que ir de este punto morado
no no perdón me equivoqué es lo siento
en realidad vamos de este punto naranja
al verde verdad
cogemos s variamos t / 6 d y se parecerá
algo como esto así que nuestra
superficie fuimos de este rectángulo muy
bonito
en el plano ts y obtuvimos al
transformarlo a una superficie medio
local incluso podríamos dibujar algunas
otras cosas por aquí digamos algún valor
arbitrario de de bs
digamos vamos a tomar un nuevo color
vamos a hacerlo en blanco así que
digamos que mantuviéramos ese constante
y variamos t
esto se vería de esta forma y en la
superficie se vería bueno no sé a lo
mejor quizás se vea como algo de este
estilo no así que puedes tener una idea
de cómo se vería la superficie
ahora dado esto quiero que piense sobre
cómo serían estas cantidades y cuando vi
y quiero que cuando visualicemos esto
seamos capaces de usar los resultados
que hemos visto en los vídeos anteriores
para hacer algo que yo creo que es
bastante útil
que vamos a tomar arbitrariamente alguna
s y una t así que digamos este sería el
punto este sería el punto déjenme
elegirlo aquí digamos este que estoy
pintando el punto ese combate
muy bien así que si pusiéramos estos
valores esto me lo mapea y bueno quiero
pintarlo de tal suerte que sea
consistente digamos que lo mapea de este
lado no cerquita del morado muy bien así
que aquí está r de ese combate
para algún aceite particulares digo
podría ponerle otro otro nombre pero
bueno en fin podría llamarles x com y
entonces este punto sería rx y el punto
es que se mataría a este punto de aquí
así que este ere es la que estamos
diciendo ahora vamos a ver qué pasa si
tomamos digamos que pasa si nos movemos
en la dirección de ese es decir digamos
que aquí está ese y ahora vamos a
movernos tantito por una diferencial una
diferencial un pequeñísimo cambio de sí
así que esto sería ese más un cambio muy
pequeño en ese y entonces tendríamos el
punto déjenme hacerlo con un mejor color
digamos en amarillo tendríamos el punto
s más del más una diferencial de ese
coma
ajá combate donde la diferencial es un
cambio muy pequeño y que es como lo
vamos a mapear aquí bueno si aplicamos
este punto a través de la función vamos
a obtener otro en la superficie que más
o menos se ve así por aquí
este justo de aquí es r de ese más delta
de ese combate
eso es lo que es y ahora esto es cuando
nos movemos en ese en un cambio muy
pequeño esta distancia aquí lo podemos
entender como desde un cambio súper
pequeño y cuando lo veamos entonces lo
ponemos a través de nuestra función
vectorial y aquí está déjenme la copio y
la pegó
para que tengamos siempre muy presentes
de qué es lo que estamos hablando
ok ahí está déjenme ponerla justo ahí
así que aquí ya queda más claro de qué
es lo que estamos pasando tomamos una
pequeña un pequeñísimo cambio en el
punto azul de aquí que es ese combate y
obtuvimos un vector que apuntaba al r de
ese combate en la superficie así que
cuando agregamos un de ese a los valores
en donde se encuentra la s obtuvimos
este punto amarillo y bajo la función es
un vector que apunta ahí así que
regresemos a los resultados de la última
presentación o del último vídeo esto que
es es rds de ese combate ok
bueno eso es esto de aquí es justo este
punto es el vector que apunta a esa
posición ok y el otro que subraya en
azul es el punto azul justamente que
pinte ahí esto es básicamente esto es
básicamente la diferencia de dos
vectores ok es decir estamos hablando
del vector que apunta
el vector que apunta al hacer la resta
es este vector verdad el que apunta del
azul al amarillo se ve justo así así que
esto es justo el vector que pintamos y
tiene sentido verdad este vector azul
más el vector naranja ajá nos da el
vector amarillo que es esta suma lo
vemos como un triángulo ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo pero en la dirección de t
digamos se me están acabando los colores
pero vamos a tomar otro a ver volvamos
al rosa o quizás al magenta así que si
tengo aquí mi punto de ese combate ahora
agregamos un poquito en la dirección
dt es decir vamos a agregar un una d es
una vete perdón muy pequeña un cambio
muy pequeño enter y ese es el punto de
ahí verdad esta distancia es un dt que
lo puedes ver de esta forma ok y ahora
si introducimos ese punto morado en
nuestra función r lo que vamos a obtener
es un punto por aquí verdad sobre la
superficie quizás deba dibujarlo por
aquí es un vector que apunta a ese punto
ok se mata a ese vector muy bien ahora
por el mismo argumento que hicimos del
lado s este este punto o este vector
ok este vector que es el r con rds
perdón de coma temas de t es exactamente
este de acá arriba ok que como ya vimos
es una diferencia y entonces estamos
hablando del vector que apunta del azul
al morado perdón al magenta ok
otra vez esto espero o sea un poquito de
repaso para la cuestión de sumas y
restas de vectores lo voy a pintar ahora
en blanco esto va a ser justo lo que
estamos escribiendo del lado derecho y
que estoy en marcando en blanco ahora
como ya puedes imaginar si tomas el
vector azul
más el vector blanco te da el vector
morado verdad y tiene sentido todo esto
tiene sentido geométricamente así que
algunas veces es interesante ver qué es
lo que está pasando así tengo estos dos
este es un vector bajo el cual estamos
parametrizado la superficie y al cambiar
nuestros nuestra s por un cambio muy
pequeño obtenemos un vector que también
se mueve sobre la superficie e
igualmente cuando cambiamos t por un
pequeño número así que puede que no
recuerdes muy bien esto lo he hecho en
muchos vídeos pero lo que yo quiero
ahora es calcular la magnitud del
producto cruz de estos dos vectores y
y cuando tengo la magnitud del vector
resultante de tomar el producto cruz
obtiene uno primero obtiene un vector
que es ortogonal a los otros dos verdad
pero si tomamos la magnitud esto es
igual al área del paralelogramo el área
del paralelogramo
d
el área del paralelogramo
definido por
a ive
ok que es lo que lo que estoy diciendo
aquí bueno aquí tenemos este vector a
tenemos este vector b
estos son los vectores a ive entonces
cuando tomamos el producto cruz de este
par vamos a obtener un tercer vector y
éste es perpendicular a ambos es digamos
como que se sale de la pantalla un poco
este sería a cruz b pero la magnitud de
este de este que tomamos el producto
cruz lo que vamos a obtener de la
magnitud de este vector es digamos la
magnitud es qué tan grande es pero eso
va a ser igual al área del paralelogramo
definido por ahí ve y ya hemos probado
en otros vídeos de álgebra lineal
quizás lo pruebe aquí de nuevo bueno
bueno no no quiero entrar en mucho
detalle pero ya lo he hecho antes no
quiero hacer este vídeo más largo así
que el paralelogramo definido por ahí ve
digamos si aquí ponen se imaginan que
ponen aquí una copia de a una copia idea
y aquí una copia debe
digamos así sobrepuestos este
paralelogramo definido por ahí ve baja
si si regresamos al ejemplo de la
superficie y fuéramos a tomar el
producto cruz de este vector naranja y
el blanco entonces tendremos el área de
un de un cachito de un paralelogramo es
digamos cercano a la superficie verdad
entonces este paralelogramo al al
naranja y al blanco se vería algo así
verdad si tomo el producto cruz de ambos
eso es vamos a obtener el área de este
paralelogramo
ahora ustedes pueden decir que que esta
superficie lo estamos construyendo con
paralelo gramos de cambios muy
pequeñitos verdad estamos haciendo
paralelo gramos infinitamente pequeños o
tenemos una infinidad de paralelo gramos
muy pequeños infinitamente pequeños así
que esto a lo mejor es medio raro pero
hemos aproximado ya el área debajo de
las curvas verdad con un buen de
rectángulos y de hecho con rectángulos
infinitamente pequeños así que este va a
ser un pequeño cambio en la superficie
de la misma forma que lo hicimos con
curvas y lo vamos a llamar de sigma por
un pequeño cambio en la superficie y
ahora
vamos a tomar una infinita suma de
infinitas de sig más pequeñas verdad así
que la superficie la superficie
digamos el área de la superficie va a
ser igual a la integral sobre toda la
superficie d
así es como denotamos la superficie con
una sigma verdad entonces una superficie
es como una estructura bidimensional
verdad y vamos a tomar todos los
pequeños de sigma todas las pequeñas
áreas de los paralelo gramos ahora que
es una décima bueno ya hemos visto que
la de sigma puede ser representada elba
como el valor del área de esta pequeña
parte verdad de la superficie de este
paralelogramo representado por el
producto cruz de estos dos vectores y
digo aunque esto no es una matemática
rigurosa el punto central aquí es es
poder llegar a la integral de superficie
así que vamos a escribir de sigma igual
al producto cruz vamos a hacer el
producto cruz del vector naranja y
tienen el vector naranja en realidad
como vimos en el último vídeo lo que
escribí en naranja era la parcial de r
con respecto a
se me está acabando se me están acabando
los el espacio déjenme déjenme ponerlo
así la parcial de r respecto de ese de
ese y en realidad no es sólo tomar el
producto cruz porque el producto cruz es
un vector y eso nos servirá para cuando
queramos sacar integral de superficie
para funciones de valores vectoriales
sino que también hay que sacar la
magnitud pero es la magnitud de quien de
este de este vector cruz el vector
blanco verdad que ya habíamos dicho que
era este la parcial de r respecto de tdt
así que es la parcial de r respecto de t
dt y luego obtenemos la magnitud de eso
y eso es lo que va a hacer a nuestro
pequeño cambio en el área o el área del
pequeño paralelogramo de aquí arriba
verdad
ahora pueden puede que a lo mejor no
recuerden esto pero debe ser claro que
cuando uno deriva de respecto de ese ode
te siguen siendo vectores y cuando
tenemos la derivada de ese y dt son
numeritos y quizás no ya no lo recuerdes
pero vimos en álgebra lineal que cuando
tenemos el producto cruz y lo estamos
multiplicando por escalares entonces
podemos sacar los escalares fuera del
producto verdad así que esto será esto
va a ser igual a la magnitud del
producto cruz del producto cruz de la
parcial de r respecto de ese cruz cruz
la parcial de r respecto de t eso
sacamos la magnitud y después
multiplicamos por de ese y de t que son
estos dos chicos no de ese i
dt pero quienes dsi dt
bueno aquí escribimos el área que es
tomar la suma de todos estos pequeños de
sigma si por supuesto no hay forma de
evaluar de evaluarlos pero si sabemos
que son esta misma cosa y tomamos todos
los de ese si de test de ese porte pues
es un área en esta en esta región de los
parámetros verdad en el plano etc así
que si multiplicamos este producto por
de este producto cruz de las parciales
luego sacamos la magnitud y luego
tomamos estas pequeñas áreas de ese y dt
pues entonces sumamos todos
ok sumamos todos
y cuando sumemos todo sobre toda la
región entonces obtendremos todos los
paralelo gramos de la superficie y
obtendremos el área de la superficie así
que podemos escribir ya ya un poquito
más más centrado en este asunto
espero que tenga mucho sentido y que
puedan visualizarlo podemos decir que la
integral de la superficie de los décimas
de nuestros pequeños paralelogramo sobre
la superficie va a ser igual en vez de
tomar la suma sobre toda la superficie
va a ser
va a ser la suma sobre todos los peces y
dt es verdad en esta región en el plan
oeste de este producto cruz que ya
sabemos cómo hacer verdad eso realmente
es una integral doble así que va a ser
una integral doble sobre toda la región
digamos del área a que eres la que
tenemos acá arriba en la región de los
parámetros está toda esa
de esta cosa verdad que es la magnitud y
que voy a escribir aquí en amarillo y
luego escribir que es la magnitud de la
parcial de r respecto de s cruz la
parcial de r respecto de t ajá de s dt
que ya lo sabemos calcular verdad
simplemente tenemos que ver cómo se
comportan este producto cruz como
evaluarlo y después esto realmente nos
va a representar una integral de
superficie muy fácil y que de hecho
sabemos cómo calcular y en los próximos
vídeos vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos
ahora vamos a dar en estos vídeos el
área de algunas superficies no así que
estas dos expresiones figuran lo que es
el área de la superficie al sumar todos
los pequeños paralelogramo que son como
parches asociados con cada
con cada pequeño paralelogramo ok
tendremos algún valor definido para para
para ello verdad ahora qué pasaría si yo
tengo una función f x 10 e está definida
en todas las superficies ok y queremos
ver cómo cómo se comporta una integral
respecto a esta función en este espacio
tridimensional y bueno en realidad lo
que vamos a obtener
lo que queremos hacer es figurar nos qué
pasa si si para cada uno de estos
paralelo gramos fuéramos a multiplicarlo
por el valor de la función en cada punto
es decir lo podríamos escribir de esta
forma verdad esto simplemente sería la
integral déjenme poner otro color la
integral bajan sobre toda la superficie
de f de x y z de sigma ok y esto sería
simplemente igual a esto que tenemos es
escrito acá arriba pero multiplicado por
una f de este lado entonces vamos a
integrar sobre todo el área a muy bien
de la región de fx iceta y esto
multiplicado por la magnitud de la
parcial de r respecto de s cruz la
parcial de r respecto de t tomamos la
magnitud de eso y multiplicamos por de s
dt muy bien y por supuesto estamos
integrando con respecto a de aceite y
esperamos que podamos expresar esta
función en términos de aceite debido a
la parametrización verdad cada una
x 6 z son funciones de s&p
así que evaluado en la función pues
simplemente nos da una función de aceite
es pérez las visualizaciones de esto no
son muy claras de hecho tiene
aplicaciones en física es más fácil ver
el área de la superficie así que lo que
vamos a hacer en los próximos vídeos es
un poquito medio peludo para calcular
pero no es tan difícil vamos a ver unos
ejemplos y lidiar con ello